m
[Musique]
je suis dit que mon chien et donc il
peut toucher les pattes ils le voient et
le chat bleu même aller avec
on peut se toucher on sent la chaleur à
travers là c'est très très agréable n'a
pas pu venir le voir pendant deux mois
et voilà la surprise c'est génial l'idée
c'était de pouvoir recevoir les familles
et les résidents en toute sécurité avec
toutes les règles étaient un poil dans
la gestion du public
donc on a d'un côté un sage qui était
réservé aux résidents ont peu premiers
pas sur le ferme pour pouvoir rentrer
ensuite dans la bulle il dans la bulle
qui est des formes circulaires
le résident et la famille sont séparés
par du phare rations et pêche sont
transparents en fait chacun à son
édition
là
vendus
[Musique]